cancel barstool this place is bad
[Music]
i'm ricky velez i have a special coming
out on hbo on october 23rd cult here's
everything watch that and i'm here to
answer the internet
uh if you could be homeless in any city
where would you choose florida
you don't know who's homeless and who's
not
yeah
you could be in a bathing suit at all
times everybody be like that guy's not
homeless he's just florida
if you had to win a game show to stay
alive which game show would you choose a
wheel of fortune i
think why why not
it seems like the most fun yeah
all right
i would go prices right
yeah
because i just i don't know i feel like
that's all luck and i'm not good at a
lot of things would you rather
be the best looking dude in the world or
able to read minds
i don't know man i think i'd probably
want to be
you'd be the if you're the best looking
guy you don't really have to worry about
what the [ __ ] people think so therefore
you win
yeah yeah i'm better looking than
everybody [ __ ] what they think uh if you
can have an endless supply of anything
what would it be
printer ink
i'm so sick of buying that [ __ ] dude
printer ink man
every time i go it's so expensive too
it's so annoying no dude the printer ink
thing pisses me off and they sell it
this big it's 50 bucks it sucks if you
could put any franchise restaurant in
your house what would it be benihana
that's [ __ ] sick dude i went to
what's-his-name's crib uh uh
actually i signed an nda about this so
never mind
let's go
if you can make your dick as big as you
wanted but for every inch you would lose
two years off your life how would you be
like dude people die early in my family
so like
no i can't shoot i can't no dude no dude
people die at 50.
it's like no i can't do that that's
dangerous
uh would you rather know the lyrics to
every song ever or get five thousand
dollars five thousand dollars [ __ ] the
guy that knows every song that guy's so
annoying
and he's awesome at karaoke i hate that
guy if you're good at karaoke ah you're
the worst i can't stand karaoke people
anybody that requests that like when
it's like a day to go out with your
friends like that's your worst friend if
you can pick one other part of your body
that could cause you to orgasm
what would it be
that's funny
yo suck my thumb
yeah that'd be oh just
yeah then you can make it touch your
dick too double orgasm
who's winning more than i am
if you got home and your tv was missing
would you call the cops or just buy a
new tv i would buy a new tv like yeah
i'm not it would be weird but at the
same time i would just be like yeah
let's just go cop you can get a tv for
so cheap now walk into best buy and
they're just like yeah it's like three
printer ink things if you could have one
fictional dog as your pet
who would it be
i feel like snoopy's depressing to have
around
she was like uh
um goofy man he was cool as [ __ ]
i like goofy yeah he was like he was
when i was a kid i really liked him
it'd be cool to get back there you know
um if you were serving a life sentence i
worry about jail all the time by the way
would you rather be the prisoner
everyone fears or the one nobody knows
yeah i think you want to be
the guy that
you you you just don't want to be
anything and like i don't want to be no
i'm like like i said small man like it's
a bad place for me
i talk about it in the special man i'd
be poop boy the guy that just wakes up
and rubs [ __ ] all over himself every day
leave me alone
leave me alone
dude i'd rather be poop boy than the
other option you know what the other
option is
um this is a weird one
would you rather go to a circus alone or
give your mom a foot massage
my mom's dead dude this is a terrible
question
you guys need to do some research i'm
triggered cancel bar stool this place is
bad it's not for people that don't have
moms
bro answer the question man
i mean that would be a cold foot massage
all right big thanks for watching ati
anybody else who you want to see any up
and coming comics anybody who you think
deserves to be a superstar comment below
we'll go get em make sure you subscribe
to the channel right now